i definitely want to start with do you
feel like like i feel like watching your
work recently the last few years i feel
like you've won the actors lottery in
terms of the projects you've gotten to
do and the directors you've gotten to
work with um does it feel like that at
all to you or have you been able to take
a moment to appreciate you know the the
uh what what has happened the last few
years
i mean the project is just a project
until it until you make it you know what
i mean so
i think i've i think i've been very
fortunate
in
um
attracting people who
[Music]
feel like they can do something
with
what i bring or what i what i try to
bring to a to a piece
um
and that's that's cool you mean there's
nothing more emboldening than that um
as a as a human being and as an artist
um and then to
uh i mean have i taken time to
kind of sit with it and and acknowledge
it i mean
moments like this
i do you know when you say something
like that i i have to ponder i have to
stop and go oh yeah i guess yes that's
right you know um
and i'm extremely grateful for it and
and and the gratitude i think my love
language is is actionable you know i'm
you know i'm a service love language
kind of guy you know service so i go
okay that's happened i'm very happy
about that
what else can i how else can i give back
how can i do another one
you know that can have that same or
equal or greater impact you know so
that's how i metabolized uh
the last few years
i want to start uh regarding this film i
want to start with congratulations i
thought you did such a great job and i
also on camera want to give a big thank
you to netflix for uh for making this
movie and allowing a story like this to
be told um i know that you like to
research stuff when you researched the
role and got ready uh what were some of
the things that really surprised you to
learn that maybe you weren't aware of
i would say the fact that he
left home when he was young
you know
um and that he wasn't from the places
that he
occupied you know that he had this
nomadic
spirit
about him um
which i very much like
and then i would say
the second thing would be just how
um
i mean there's a book and anyone can
read it uh the adventures of nat love uh
that would dick right adventures of dead
would have not loved also known as that
with dick right
and when you read that book you realize
how fantastical his life
seemed you know from his point of view
and that's something i didn't think of
you know like
here's a man who has who actually wrote
an autobiography with a certain
perspective about who he is
you know that he he himself saw himself
as a myth you know um
and that gave me a lot of information
about how bold and how
um
clear and and and the the frequency of
choices i could you know propose to you
know james samuel uh the director for uh
for the heart of they fall in in this
rendition of that love
um i would imagine that well every
western has a big third act third act
shootout
it's it's part of the genre what was it
like for you being part of a big western
shootout did you did was it a lot of fun
or was it more like technically
challenging if you will
i was a lot of fun i mean the tech i
guess i'd say both because
it can only be fun if you can do it
technically you know what i mean
otherwise it's a headache and a
nightmare and you're terrified um but
early on uh
james and i came to the conclusion you
know not even early on i said i asked i
said i want to do all the stunts all of
them horses guns
shoot out all of it hand-to-hand all of
it
and um
again i would now think next to netflix
for letting me do that um because every
stunt in this film is me you know uh
which is which is something that you
know doesn't happen nowadays um
but uh no when when when you see that i
mean and we and we cranked it up i mean
what was in the original script and what
we ended on
uh it's completely different you know
not completely different but there is a
there's a twist that we put in
um as far as the battle
um it was like because i kept saying him
it's like
because when we were shooting it it's
like it was like 70 yards no not even it
was like no it's about 70 yards from the
top of the church down to the um the
rufus bug mansion and i was like that's
a football field man we got to get to
that end zone and when you get to the
red zone what happens naturally is like
it's fire and brimstone and everybody's
acting up it's not just one guy two guys
i mean it's literally people are coming
out of the woodwork there is strength
coming from that defensive line
offensive line that you've not felt
before you know like that's what it's
got to feel like and so
with that in mind working backwards
knowing that we wanted it to be so
visceral and also romantic and also
poetic
we i then had to go okay so you work
weekends
you live with the gun flipping it moving
it you ride the horse you know to your
legs
you can't feel your legs and you can
feel your legs again i mean that's what
you do that's just what it is you know
um
so yeah i mean that was the experience
of it um
and i was very excited to to add to the
canon of that you know that third act
gun shootout as you say
yeah i man i have so many more things
but um i i as a huge fan of marvel i am
just curious when when you met when when
feige and you met with marvel and
everything to get involved did they tell
you like the full
storyline of what they envisioned for
you and what they wanted you to
accomplish or was it sort of like i
trust what marvel's been doing
just yeah this is great i want to be a
part of this
well i know i knew everything that
everyone else knew you know and still do
actually you know where it's like
um
this is the role you know
and this is where we're starting
um
that's as far as we got you know and
that was enough for me you know to
understand who this
who to try to understand who this
character was you know and when i looked
at the significance
of uh
of kang you know in the mcu
it i picked i agreed to the role the
same way i agreed to
you know
any other film that i do what is the
responsibility of the character you know
can the
can the world move forward without them
you know um can the scene move forward
without them
um
and if it can then i'm okay and if it
can't then it's something i want to take
on and take that responsibility
i want to go back to the harder they
fall uh i read that when kovitz shut
down the movie you stayed in santa fe to
be able to
ride your horse every day um can you
sort in and that sort of speaks to the
level of your commitment
towards the characters you're playing
can you sort of talk about that
yeah i mean i'm an actor you know and
and
everyone does their job differently you
know but for me it's kind of all i it's
what i do you know if i'm not acting and
if i'm not working on
my craft you know
that's like it's like your little
private thing that you have and if you
don't have that
for me if i don't have that private
thing it's hard for me to
it's hard for me to turn it off and turn
it on you are you aren't you know and so
uh it was also like a
a spiritual decision to
to just try to keep the light on
you know um
the cast knew that i had stayed
a production company knew that i had
stayed um
and it was uh it was a banner you know
it was a war banner that when the time
comes
you know that love will be here you know
um preparing and being ready you know uh
but also it did give me time to
um
really
i mean you you you have the time you
have and you make it work but it gave me
time to really get quiet with that and
understand him more and
kind of be able to you know there's
moments in the film that are you know
huge moments in the film that are just
improv you know those improv
scenes don't come on the day those
improv scenes came you know
during the middle of the winter when the
world was shut down and i'm just you
know
sitting at the house looking at my dog
reading the script you know what i mean
um
would i do it again yeah i mean do i
hope to have to no
completely i gotta stop there man i
really enjoy your work thank you so much
for giving me your time
absolutely brother thank you
you